what's about your facial hair Erlich
Bachman on your character on Silicon
Valley always has interesting and new
and different facial hair and I'm
curious how does TJ Miller the how does
to Jane Miller I had to sneak in here
single how does TJ Miller the actor
decide when the facial hair is right for
the character I get to decide sort of
what the facial hair is each season and
Mike judge now I said you know just do
whatever you want and Kate really
actually gets into the idea that I have
this stupid facial hair so I thought
muttonchops that became a mustache
that's pretty stupid
then I saw Kate and she was I was like
what do you think pretty stupid right
and she goes I'm sorry TJ I just I
thought it was gonna look much stupider
I just I said you don't think it looks
stupid she goes no we have transparency
in our relationship and I want to tell
you I thought it was gonna be sort of
like a a hair ribbon that was draped we
didn't speak to each other you fought
because she didn't think your facial
hair was stupid enough those are the
arguments that happen in my household
you